In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of
my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God and in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and
do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires and may you my beloved
divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy
will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a
breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints,
especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit
and infuse in me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these
writings and prayers, amen. So let's begin with October the 24th 1925 and here we continue
the message that we left last week where Jesus was talking about the one act that exists in the
divine will which contains all other acts and so we want to pick this up here in this one as well.
So Louisa said as I was in my usual state I felt my sweet Jesus move in my interior. Now
beside that of course you put Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within you and one Corinthians
316. No you not that you are the temple of the living God. I could hear his death rattle she said
and I too felt I was agonizing together with him because she is long since inseparable with him
and this is going to be quite important now in one of the messages coming up. She's long since
inseparable so if he agonizes she feels it. If she agonizes he feels it. Then after I had
suffered for a little while together with Jesus he told me my daughter thinking about my passion
compassionating with me or as we would say sympathizing with him in his pains is very pleasing.
I feel I'm not alone in my pains and I have with me the company of the creature. Well Proverbs 8
31 says God delights to be with the children of men he actually wants our company. You also read in
Genesis 3 18 that God walked with Adam in the cool of the day when Adam was in the divine will.
So God actually wants our company. So I have with me the company of the creature because of whom
I suffer and whom I love so much. We cost him an awful lot and as I have her with me my suffering
becomes sweeter for me. In other words when we actually join him in union that lessens his suffering
because the suffering he has already suffered for us is bearing fruit. So naturally it's sweeter
for him how hard he said is isolation in suffering. When I see myself alone and I've no one to whom
to entrust my pains nor anyone to whom to give the fruit which my pains contain and so I remain as
though drowned with pains and with love. Now notice the two expressions drowned with pains and with
love. You hear Louisa saying that over and over again particularly when Jesus is on the cross
in the hours of the Passion that he's literally submerged or drowned in pain but the pain that is
the worst is his love that needs to reach out and do anything pay any price in order to save us.
Therefore he said as my love can endure no more I come to you to suffer within you just to have
the company and you with me the pains of my passion which are in act. Now as he's going to talk about
the one act in the divine will everything that God does is alive and in act no matter what century
you and I live in and when we enter into the Passion we can actually genuinely join Jesus in
Gethsemane. I learned this many years ago long before I heard of the divine will when I was going
through a very very difficult crisis and I said to the Lord what do I do? How do I pray? What can I
say? All I'm experiencing is agony and he said come into the garden he said kneel in front of me
so that the two of us bend over together and I'll put my hand on your hands
so that the two of us are agonizing together for the salvation of the world. That's what he's
looking for not just that we think about it but that we actually enter into it. So the pains of my
passion he said are in act and we do this in order to repeat what I did and suffered in my humanity.
Now this is very important for us who do the hours of the passion. To repeat my passion in act in the
creature is different I would say very different from one who only thinks about and sympathizes
with my pains. You know when we do the stations of the crafts and we just go pop from one to the
next and say a little prayer in each one that's a very different thing to entering in and echoing
all his acts and joining him in the salvation of souls. Of course you can offer your stations of
the cross for that but doing it this way is completely different it's on a much higher plane.
The first is an act of my life that is repeating the passion and it takes my place in order to
repeat my pains and I feel I'm given back the effects and the value of a divine life.
But the other way when one merely thinks about the pains and sympathizes with me it is mere
company of the creature that I feel. So there you have the difference. One is you just simply think
about it and the Lord has your company but the other one is actually entering in and participating.
That's a different subject. But do you know in whom I can repeat the pains of my passion in act?
It is in one who has my will as the center of life. Now I want you to notice that expression.
We talk about living in the divine will and we look at it from different angles but this is very
precise that the divine will is actually the center of that person's life. That means that
the divine will is the operator in that person's life. Be it done unto me according to your word.
That the the Lord's word is actually being done in me with my consent. That's the
the consecration that our blessed mother did and that we're trying to emulate.
So he then goes on to explain the one single act which is terribly important.
My will alone is one single act. We have to do millions of acts to do something.
My will alone is one single act. It has no succession of acts. Now the astronomers call
what they have discovered. They've gone back beyond the Big Bang and they've discovered a single point
and they call it a singularity. It'll take them a while to put a different name on it.
The prime mover, the beginning of all things, they now know they've long since come to the
conclusion that any primary school child could have told them and that is that a Big Bang needs a
match. So they've gone way beyond that back to the singularity. Now what the Lord is telling us is
that the divine will is one single act which embraces everything, absolutely everything past,
present and future according to us and it embraces the whole of eternity, therefore it's completely
immense. So you're going to hear Louisa say more and more and more as she goes on in these volumes
that she enters into an immensity of space. Now she's entering into the divine will and that
it's endless and once you go in there's no way out. Yes because it's eternal.
This single act is as though fixed to one point which never moves. There's the immutability of God
and this point is eternity. Now when a person dies they leave the dimensions of time and space
and they go into that eternal now. So while being one single act, the prime act,
the endless act, its circumference is so immense that nothing can escape but because it's infinite.
It embraces everything and everyone with one single embrace because everything starts
from that prime act as one single act. So everything starts there, everything is contained in this.
So he's going to go on and tell us that if you have this divine will inside of you then look
at what you can actually read. So the creation, the redemption and sanctification, the three theats
are one single act as far as the divinity are concerned and only because it is one single act
it has the power to make all acts its own. It absorbs everything into this one center.
But as you know from Hebrews 1214 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter there. Therefore divine will
acts are required to go in there. It has the power to make all acts its own as if they were only one.
So all the acts coming from all of us all together, all generations got right into that one center.
Now one who lives in my will possesses this single act. This is where the revelation really is
and it's no wonder that she takes part in the pains of my passion as though in act. In other
words when you enter into the agony as I have just illustrated it you're actually there.
You are actually participating. In this single act she finds as though in act or creator creating
the creation and forming one single act with her God she creates together with him so we
mustn't forget to actually turn that into a prayer and actually create the universe with him.
It's unbelievable. Flowing as one single act in all created things and forming the glory of creation
for her creator. Her love shines over all created things so we have to put our I love you on all
that came out of that one single act. She enjoys and she takes pleasure in them. She loves them
as things belonging to herself and to her God. So watch this now I think this is beautiful.
In that single act she has a note like a musical note that echoes the whole of the divine operating.
So if millions of us are putting that little note into God's act in creation then we have
a beautiful orchestra from the earth. And in her emphasis of love she says what is yours is mine,
what is mine is yours all glory and honor and love be for our creator. So this is where you put
your signature. I've said a number of times that as far as I'm concerned doing the rounds means
putting your signature on everything and saying yes I agree to everything you've done and I join
you I want to be part of it. What is yours is mine what is mine is yours. So then we go on to the next
stage which is the second fiat. In this single act she also finds the whole of redemption in act
and she makes all of it her own. She suffers my pains as if they were her own. She flows within
everything that I did. She flows in my prayers, in my pains, in my words, in everything. We need to
just sort of remember that when we're praying that we say Jesus I want to pray through your prayers.
I want to suffer whatever I'm suffering through your sufferings.
I'm going through you with everything. I want to eat this meal with your eating of meals on the earth.
I want to rest at night in your rest. Everything is in him, through him with him and in him as the
church has been teaching us. So in everything she has a note of reparation. Now celebration and joy
in creation and reparation in redemption. This means that for any of us who claim to be living in
the divine will if reparation isn't there one of the important signs that were in the divine will
is missing. And so instead of complaining about our pains and aches and I've had loads of them
in the last six weeks instead of that you start realizing you have the privilege of reparation.
But you're not doing it on your own. You're doing it through him with him and in him in the divine
will and therefore it has incredible power. So the soul has a note of reparation and of compassion,
of love because reparation was not entirely out of love and of substitution for my life,
Jesus says. So we're taking an act of part in this thing. Most people look at the passion of
Jesus from the outside. An awful lot of people don't want to look at it because it's so horrifying.
But he asks us and he has brought us through Louisa's revelations right inside of his passion
so that we can see it from the inside. And then he asks us to participate and to put in our little
note as well. And I think that's beautiful that when you, when eventually everything is revealed at
the end of time, the world will see that you and I had a little note of reparation in there as well
that we actually agreed and said, yeah, want to be part of it. I want to be part of the redemption
of the world. Isn't that incredible? I was part of the creation. I'm now part of the redemption.
Watch where we're going that we're part of the sanctification of the world. It's privileged beyond
privilege. So she has a note of reparation, of compassion, of love and of substitution for my life.
In this single act, she finds everything. She makes everything her own and she places her
quite love everywhere. So it's very important for us to realize that you're not just putting a child
to her. I love you on things. You're actually participating because when you hear Louisa saying
she enters into the divine will, she's entering into a huge experience. She's not just saying words
from her lips. We can make the mistake of saying words from her lips. So in this single act,
she finds everything. She makes everything her own and she places her quite love love everywhere.
This is why the living in my will is the prodigy of prejudice. It is the enchantment of God and of
heaven as they see the littleness of the creature. In other words, we're such tiny little things and
they see that we have put a little note, our own little musical note, into creation and into redemption
and into sanctification, that our names are actually written on the three fiettes like this brilliant.
The Holy Trinity and all of heaven sees that the littleness of the creature
flow in the things of their creator. And like a solar ray bound to this single act, she diffuses
everywhere and in everything because the divine will is everywhere and in everything. Therefore,
I recommend to you, he said, even at the cost of your life, never go out of this single act of my
will, that I may repeat in you as though in act creation, redemption and sanctification.
Now, since this sounds incredible beyond incredible, he gives us two examples which are, by comparison
what we've just said, perfectly mundane. And the first example is the sun and the second example is
our own bodies. So he first of all gives you the elevated revelation and then gives you a perfectly
ordinary illustration so that you can take it on board. And those of you who are teachers,
you've heard me saying over and over, always use very simple ordinary illustrations and then
people get it. So watch this. So let's take an example of the sun. Jesus said, nature also contains
similarities of this single act. In the atmosphere, the sun has one single act. From the moment it's
created by God, it does nothing but this one thing which it gives light and heat. It's light,
it's heat are so transfused together as to become completely inseparable from each other. Now,
in the same way as we have to become inseparable from him. And from up high, he has told us it's
very important that the sun, excuse me, for using the language lives so far away from us,
otherwise we'd interfere. And from up high, it remains always in the act of sending light and
heat. It has one thing to do. But there are so many effects that it produces because of this one
act that it repeats endlessly. So from up high, it knows how to do only this one single act,
the circumference of its light which descends down below is so great as to embrace all the earth.
Now, if you're studying astronomy, of course, it not only embraces the earth, it embraces any
other planet that comes within any kind of a distance from it. And with its embrace, it produces
innumerable effects constituting itself the life and glory of all created things down to the
simple mundane fact that we all feel in good humor when the sun shines and we don't when it doesn't.
By virtue of this single act, it has the power of enclosing each plant within itself
and to summit administers development to others' maturation of fruit, to others again, sweetness
and to others' fragrance. So it depends on what the plant actually needs as to what the sun actually
does for it. Now, take a look at that a little bit slowly later on. The sun is doing the same thing
all the time. What plants are at different stages of growth. Now, it's the same with us.
The divine will is pouring all its grace and all its beauty into us all the time. But we're all at
different stages and so it produces different effects in us, according to where we're at.
The divine will is not at fault and the sun is not at fault. It depends on what stage of growth
will happen to be in. So by virtue of this single act, it has the power of enclosing
or yet each plant within itself. It can be said that the whole earth begs life from the sun. That's
correct. And that each plant, even the littlest blade of grass from the sun, it besetures each
fruit that was produced from the sun. Sorry, the sentence there is wrongly translated.
But the sun never changes its action. It glories and always doing the same thing.
So the divine will is pouring all its grace down upon us. But it's producing different effects
everywhere, according to where we're at. So now he comes to human nature or let's put it straight,
the body, the miracle of the body. This also has a symbol of the single act. And what Jesus does
is he goes to the beating of the heart and he says human life begins with the heartbeat.
It's an interesting one now for those studying gynecology. The heartbeat always does the same
thing. It simply beats. It can do nothing but beat. However, by virtue of this beat, it affects the
whole of human life and its effects are innumerable. As it palpitates, in each heartbeat, it makes
the blood circulate and the members up to the outermost part. And as it palpitates, it gives
strength to the feet in order to walk, to the hands to work, to them out to speak, to the mind to think.
It administers warmth and strength to the whole person. Everything depends on the heartbeat.
So much so that if the heartbeat is a little labored, one loses energy and will not be able
to operate, the intelligence becomes dim and one is full of pains with the general sense of
ill being. If the heartbeat ceases, life ceases. The power of the single act repeated continuously
is great. Hence, he wants continuous rounds and he keeps Louisa on the go all the time.
Now, what he asks of her, he's not asking from each individual in this class because we're
living a completely different life to the life Louisa lived. But insofar as we understand how to
do this, he wants us to continuously do the rounds. To me, that means putting your signature on the
three feet. This has the power of doing everything with one single act. Therefore, neither past,
present nor future exist in this act. This is an eternal act. And one who lives in my will already
finds herself in this single act. And just as the heart always produces a heartbeat in the body,
which constitutes the life of the body, so does my will palpitate continuously in the depth of the
soul. Beautiful. Again, with one single heartbeat, as it palpitates, as the divine will palpitates,
it gives her beauty, sanctity, strength, love, goodness and wisdom. So this is where it is so
necessary for us to remain conscious of the presence of God in us so that we can be conscious to give
our yes, our surrender all the time, so that these fruits can in fact be produced inside of us.
This heartbeat, that's the divine heartbeat, encloses both heaven and earth. It's like blood
circulation. It's like the circumference of light. It can be found in the highest point and in the
outermost parts. Wherever this single act is, this heartbeat of the soul has full vigor and rains
completely. There is continuous tragedy. The tragedy that only God can do. So what he's saying there is,
if the divine will really is allowed to be the center, since we're talking about heartbeat,
the pumping center, that it is doing all the action inside of the depths of our being,
then what will be produced in us is only something God can produce. It's a divine
tragedy. And therefore he said, "New heavens, new abysses of graces, surprising truths are all
discovered in this soul." And if one asks, "Where does so much good come from?" She would answer,
"United with the sun, together with the human heartbeat and with the single act of the eternal
God." I do only one thing. I do always the will of my God and I live in it. Now there you have John
8 29. I always do what pleases him. I do the will of my God. This is all my secret and it's all my
fortune. Now even though what we're reading is very deep and very wonderful and all the rest of it,
it comes down to this very simple statement. I always do what pleases him. It comes down to
something utterly simple. So having said this, Jesus disappeared, but later Louisa found herself
outside of herself with the baby Jesus in her arms. He was very pale and was shivering all over.
His lips were blue and he was cold and so emaciated as to her I was pity. Now you know from reading
these volumes that when Louisa has been given a revelation, she's then given a practice session
to know what to do about what she has received. So now she has to minister to Jesus because he's
all in need. It seemed to me that he had taken refuge in my arms in order to be defended. I pressed
him to my heart to warm him. I took his little hands and feet in my hands and I squeezed them so
that he wouldn't shiver. I kissed him and kissed him over and over again. I told him that I loved
him very very much and while I was doing this, the little baby regained color, stopped shivering.
It's what a mother would naturally do to a child in that condition. He was all restored and he clung
more tightly to me as a child would do. But while I thought that he would remain always with me,
that's her problem of course. To my surprise I saw that very gently he was going down from my knees.
In other words, you were doing this service for him but it didn't mean that he was going to stay
forever. I cried out pulling him by one arm. Jesus, where are you going? How can this be? You leave me.
He said I must go. And Louisa said, "And when are you coming back?" And Jesus answered three years
from now. Jesus says that to a woman who cannot tolerate not seeing him for a couple of hours.
So I don't have to tell if she goes into a crisis. And he took his leave and went.
But who can say my sorrow? I repeated to myself among tears and convulsions. I will not see him
again in three years from now. "Oh God, how shall I go on?" she said. And the pain was so great that
I fainted. You see, you're dealing with someone literally living at the heights of love that we
aspire to. But I mean she's there and she cannot live without him. It's actually that simple.
So she fainted and she couldn't understand anything anymore. She said, "And while I was
languishing faint, I just barely opened my eyes and I saw that Jesus had turned back. He realized
the damage he had done. And he was coming up my other knee very, very gently. And he crouched down
on my lap and he caressed me with his little hands. He kissed me and he said, "Come yourself,
come yourselves. You know I don't really leave you because he's inside of her. The two of them are
inseparable. But it's this visual presence that she wants. And as you would say, I do not leave
you. I would feel myself come round and life given back to me again. And I found myself inside of
myself with such fear that I felt myself dying. Now why did Jesus say that to her? I won't come back
for three years. It's because he needs her to have an experience of hell. And she's going to have that
on November the 1st 1925. He's going to let her experience literally the pains of hell. And it's
not that he's been cruel. It's that he's allowing her into the very depths of the sufferings that he
had to save souls. And of course it will have an absolutely incredible harvest of souls because
she will have done the hell for them. So this is November the 1st 1925. I went through most
bitter days without my sweet Jesus, the told of not seeing him anymore hammered my poor heart
like an anvil which repeated cruel hammer blows at Jesus. You have put me into a living hell.
Now she actually means this. Sometimes we say something is hell and we're just exaggerating.
Okay, she means it. So before I go on any further, I want to give you Sam 22 verses 1 to 11. My God,
my God, why have you deserted me? Okay. And verses 14 and 15. I also want to give you Sam 6 verses 4
and 6 to 7. Now there are other Sam's but you know, I'm just giving you two examples. And that is
someone really, really going through an extremely difficult time. So she said Jesus you put me into
a living hell. Even more my pains surpass the very infernal pains. Now why would she say that?
It's because she's living in the divine will and so all her actions are raised to the divine level.
The souls who land themselves in hell are not experiencing what she's experiencing because
they went in with the human will. She's experiencing divine pains and it's important for us to sort
of get that in our heads. Much the way she begins to grasp this herself. She said,
"At the damned don't love you. And since the seed of love is missing, they run away from you,
nor do they long for your embrace, their pains would become harsher with your presence because
they hate them. A love that is hated cannot stand the presence of the person who is hated.
Therefore for them your privation is more bearable. But for me, unhappy one, it's all the opposite.
I love you." Now watch this. The Lord gets her to say things that are very important pieces of
revelation for us. She said, "I love you. I feel the seed of love deep inside my bones."
Now that means that her whole being has been transformed into love. When people start out
in their journey towards God, they've got to deal with selfishness and hatred and anger and
bitterness and all the rest of it they have to deal with. And it can take a long, long time before
the self-surrenders to allow love to actually be reborn. But Louisa is not just miles but
worlds away from that in her union with God. So I feel the seed of love deep within my bones,
in my nerves, in my blood. That means my whole being has been transformed by love.
Now God is love. So that transformation is transformation into God and you'll understand
why Jesus says she's inseparable with him.
Don't you remember that having lived together for as long as 40 years you filled my bones,
my nerves, my blood, all of myself with yourself completely transfused with the presence of God
and the love of God. I felt like a garment that covered you. Now there's a very interesting
description of a living host, the garment that covered you at this brilliant.
I felt like a garment that covered you and concealed you within me. There's your living
host is beautiful. And now without you I feel emptied of everything so my bones cry out,
my nerves, my blood, everything cries out for they want the one who used to fill them.
There is a continuous cry inside of me. So for that I want to give you Sam 42, Sam 43, Sam 63.
Even my body cries for you like a dry weary land without water that Sam 63.
There's a continuous cry inside of me that lacerates me and tortures me for they want you.
Now here's a person admitting, see if the Lord didn't allow this to happen to her
we wouldn't get this confession out of her and therefore there would be something about
the transformation that happens to us in the divine will missing if this wasn't pulled out of her.
Now this wouldn't be pulled out of her except in extreme pain. Everything inside of her is crying
out for love. Everything inside of her is crying out for the presence of God. Everything inside of
her is crying out for the divine will. There you have it. She's completely there.
Without you I feel emptied of everything so my bones cry out, my nerves and my blood cries out.
They want you, the only one to fill them. There's a continuous cry inside of me that lacerates me
and tortures me for they want you who used to fill my life. Do you see then how many cruel
tearings in my poor existence suffers? In other words she feels her entire being falling apart.
I want to give you Lamentations 1, 12. Could anybody grasp the suffering that I'm going through?
In hell there aren't these atrocious pains, these cruel tearings. This void of God
possessed and loved. Look at that wonderful confession. God possessed and loved. Jesus come
back to the one who loves you. Come back to the unhappy one among the unhappy but rendered unhappy
only for you. You see more than 90 percent of people on this planet are unhappy for all kinds of
reasons. How many are unhappy because at this moment they feel the loss of Jesus? That's a different
question. She said I am rendered unhappy only for you only because of you and I can say this you alone
have rendered me unhappy. Other unhappiness I don't know. The other unhappiness is what other people
have. It comes from their sins and their faults and their problems and all the rest of it but she
only knows one unhappiness that's to be without him. What an incredible statement of a lover.
So now in the next paragraph she goes on to explain that what she's experiencing is actually
infinite pain because it's at the divine will level. Now while I was swimming in the bitter sea of the
privation of my Jesus I began to consider the pains of the heart of my Jesus to make a comparison
with the pains of my own poor heart. But instead of finding comfort in the pains of Jesus my pains
became harsher. Thinking to myself that my pains surpassed, I love that, the pains of my Jesus
because as great as they were the pains of the heart of Jesus were pains given to him by creatures.
Now watch where she's going with this it's excellent. And even if ungrateful they offend him and they
run away from him they're always finite creatures. Not an infinite being and she's unhappy because
of an infinite being. But for me these are the pains that God gives me. The ah God is not English
is that okay? In your own book you need to knock out the a all the time that's just a bad translation
of the Italian. It's not a creature who runs away from me but God the infinite being. Jesus does not
have another God who might leave him nor can he have him therefore he cannot suffer the pain which
surpasses every other pain that of being without God. It's the most perfect description of her.
Instead my pain of being without God is great, is infinite, as great and infinite as God is.
There's some statement. Ah his pierced heart has not suffered this pain and the piercing of the
pain of the divine privation is missing in his pierced heart. But Jesus did cry out from the cross
Sam 22 verse 1 my God my God why have you forsaken me and we do know that he experienced hell on the
cross at that moment. And besides as many pains as creatures might give him might Jesus never lose
his sovereignty, his dominion even over those who offend him. That puts the humility of Jesus
in a completely new life. It's incredible. It just one thought he could have absolutely destroyed his
enemies. Neither do they make him smaller nor do they fade him he loses nothing of what he is.
He's always dominant overall. He's always the eternal immense infinite lovable and adorable
being. But as for me I do not have sovereignty or dominion and by being without Jesus I become
smaller. I fade I am reduced to nothing and I love this bit. I become nauseating and unbearable
even to myself. I don't know if you've had that experience but I have. And all you can do is cry
out to the Lord to have pity on you because that is a terrible pain when you become nauseating even
to yourself. See then oh Jesus she said how my pains are greater than yours. Ah you know the pains
that creatures give you but do not know the pains that God can give and how heavy is your privation.
He's going to have to respond to that isn't he? My poor mind was speaking nonsense. She said
I felt that there was no pain that could be compared to the pain of the privation of Jesus.
That's your lamentations one, twelve again. It is a pain without beginning and without end
which of course means infinite eternal. It's incalcable, it's irreparable. That which Jesus
is such is the pain. It's very interesting. That which he is such is the pain. My poor heart was
drowned and without life and in order not to speak more nonsense I forced myself to stop comparing
my pains with those of Jesus and move on to something else. Now in my book I put 10 out of 10
beside that. In all her pain she learns to stop making this reflection on herself comparing herself
with Jesus and turn to a different direction. Now that's incredible willpower and personal control.
Only I prayed that he would give me strength and since the pain of his privation was so great
I watched this. She's only beginning to discern something when she was doing this reflection
she wasn't getting it but when she turns away from this reflection she suddenly realized she had
noted something. I noticed that the pain had a mysterious and divine sound. Note the word sound
which other pains do not have. The second thing I wanted to note is it had a weight
which surpasses the weight of all other pains put together. So we have a sound and we have weight.
So I prayed that of his goodness he would accept my pain and in view of it that he would grant me
the greatest grace. In other words she's using the pain instead of just looking at it. Instead of
just meditating on it she's actually using it and all of us must learn this from her that whatever
you're going through make sure that you use it for good. So she asked for a grace that all may know
his most holy will. So he allowed her to go into this depth of suffering to make this incredible
intercession that the divine will would come on earth as it is in heaven. That all may know his
most holy will and with its mysterious and divine sound it may resound in all the hearts.
Now she picked up the sound and realized that this had to sound in all other hearts and had to call
everyone to fulfill his most holy will. Crushing with its weight, remember the sound and the weight,
the human will, the passions and sin so that all may know you, love you and understand what the
loss of God actually means. So she was brought into experiencing the pain of hell so that she
could make this extraordinary intercession for us and that she would understand, remember a couple
of messages back we heard that the Lord was talking about the sound, the chauffeur, you know,
and when we were looking at the message just a few moments ago we have a note of creation and
note of redemption and a note of sanctification. There's music behind all of this and there needs
to be a musical sound touching the hearts and souls of everybody everywhere regardless of religion,
caste, creed, age, anything. That this note is there and Louisa suffered that that note would
actually ring in the souls of everyone. That all may know his most holy will, that all may recognize
that sound, that call, I think it's wonderful. So that all may know you, all may love you and all
may understand what the loss of God really is. But who can say all that I was thinking it would be
too long rather I would have wanted to keep everything silent and not put it on paper but of course
obedience and sister. So let's go to the next paragraph. "Then I felt exhausted no wonder and
I could take no more and my sweet Jesus having compassion on me came out from within my interior,
that's your Luke 17 21, 1 Corinthians 3 16 again and he was all labored with his mouth all filled
with blood. The blood was so much that it prevented him from speaking but with his sad gaze he asked
from my help." Now watch this. "Before the pains of Jesus I forgot my own." In his absence or temptation
was to consider her own pains and how terrible they were when she sees him in agony then immediately
love takes over and she forgets herself. It's really beautiful to see the psychology of this is
absolutely fantastic. So before his pains I forgot about my own even more since he was present I had
no more pains and I prayed him to let us suffer together. Now she's a very brave woman she's been
through hell and she's still willing to suffer with him. "Then after we suffered together for a
little while the blood from his mouth stopped and looking at the way I had reduced myself because
of his privation he'd clasped me to himself and he laid himself within me in order to fill all of
me with himself so here he is raising her to life again and then he told me poor daughter how you
have reduced yourself. You're right you know the pain of the privation of God is the greatest pain
and because it is great it took all the strength of my will to sustain you." She couldn't do this on
her own. You remember the story about the footprints when you think the Lord isn't there he's actually
carrying you but do you know what it means to suffer in my will whenever my will was there ran
your pain on earth in heaven within the saints and the angels because if you're in the divine will
it's everywhere and as it reached them that is the angels and the saints they all placed themselves
in the act of looking at you and helping you so all were turned towards you and if paradise was
capable of suffering it would have changed all of their joys and happiness into sorrow.
In other words heaven is absolutely on our side. Heaven is batting for us and wanting us to succeed
and so in all the crises that we have all saints and all the angels they're all there wanting
to help us to continue and to get up if we fall and to help us to understand and all the rest of
it so I think it's good if we become aware of their presence that they're actually with us.
I mean it's a very beautiful picture that if heaven was allowed to have sorrow they would have
been in sorrow at the pain she was going through but since heaven is not capable of suffering all
besieged graces in exchange for a pain so great and then she named the grace she wanted which was
that the divine will would be done on earth in all human beings. It's really very wonderful
the way the thing works out. The pains of the soul who lives in my will are the cross of all
they satisfy for everything and they convert the fury of divine justice into celestial joy.
That's why I'm inclined to say that he allowed Louisa to experience hell to prevent many others
from going there. So in the early volumes you have Louisa suffering for a limited amount of time
for a limited fruit. Here it's moved to a completely different plane where she's allowed to suffer
a divine pain to get this divine response from the Lord so it's really very wonderful.
Therefore pluck up courage Jesus said and never want to go out of my will and Louisa said I remained
confused. I was expecting a reproach from Jesus because of my nonsense but nothing and we remained
in perfect peace. I think it's absolutely fantastic. Now the next section I can only begin it for you
tonight. It's very interesting. We have touched upon the fiat of creation and we've touched upon
the fiat of redemption and now we touch on the fiat of sanctification and if you think this is
going to be happy you just see just how much sins are committed against the seven sacraments is just
unbelievable. Before we even begin I want to give you Ephesians 4.30 do not grieve the Holy Spirit
and Jesus is going to tell us that the Holy Spirit is grieving through all seven sacraments.
So Louisa said I was fusing myself in the Holy divine will according to my usual way and while
I was trying as much as I could to requite Jesus with my little love for all that he has done in
redemption my lovable and sweet love Jesus moving in my interior told me my daughter with your flight
in my will reach all the sacraments instituted by me to send into the depths of them and give me
your little requite love love. So there's your signature and you're I lovely again but also you
have to make reparation here. Oh how many of my secret tears you will find and how many bitter
sighs and how many suffocated moans of the Holy Spirit. His moaning is continuous before the many
dissolutions of our love. The sacraments were instituted in order to continue my life on earth
in the midst of my children but alas how many sorrows this is why I feel the necessity of your
little love it may be small but my will will make it great he does the the wonder of doing
anything in the divine will our puniness is lifted onto a completely different plane altogether.
My love does not tolerate for one who must live in my will a not to associate yourself with my
sorrows and be not to give me her little requite love love so if you're claiming to live in the
divine will he won't let you off the hook you have to be able to associate yourself with his sorrows
and secondly make her a quite love love for him to do some reparation okay therefore my daughter
see how my love moans in the sacraments so let's come to baptism first and there's something here
that I wouldn't have thought of if he hadn't said it if I see a newborn being baptized I cry
with sorrow because while through baptism I restore his innocence I find my child again
I give back to him the rights over creation which he had lost I smile at him with love and
satisfaction I make the enemy flee from him that he may no longer have any right over him I entrust
him to the angels and to all and all of heaven makes feast for him soon my smile turns to sorrow
the feast into mourning because I can see the one who is baptized will be my enemy because God sees
everything he will be a new Adam maybe even a lost soul oh how my love moans in each baptism
especially then if one adds that the minister who is baptizing does not do it with that respect
dignity and decorum which befit a sacrament that contains regeneration many times they pay more
attention to a baguette that's the trivialities of dress and having your photos taken and all the
rest of it to whatever show than to administering the sacrament so my love feels itself being pricked
by the baptizer and by the one who is baptized and it mones with on offerable mones
would you not want then to give me a requite love love a loving moon for each baptism
notice I underlined the 2.2 billion baptisms already
as to keep company in my sorrowful mones now when I say 2.2 billion baptisms I'm trying to give you
an idea of the just extraordinary number of people who've been baptized not only in our age but in
the ages before us it's probably much bigger than I've just said so let's look at confirmation
move on to the sacrament of confirmation Jesus said how many bitter sighs here while through
confirmation I restore his courage I give him the law his lost strength back I render him invincible
to all his enemies and to his passions and he is admitted to the ranks of the militia of his creator
that he may fight for the acquisition of the celestial fatherland that's Matthew 11 12
and the Holy Spirit gives him his loving kiss again lavishes a thousand caresses on him offers
himself as the companion of his career yet many times he feels himself being requited with kiss
of a traitor his caress is being despised his company being shunned how many mones how many
sighs for his return how many secret voices to the heart for the one who shuns him to the point of
tiring himself from speaking but no it's in vain therefore do you not want to give your
quite love love your loving kiss your company to the Holy Spirit who mones because of this
an election of course is not English because of this neglect I want to do confession with you as
well because in any way this is the one that scandalizes me the most but do not stop he said
keep flying and you will hear the anguishing moons of the Holy Spirit in the sacrament of penance
how much in gratitude how many abuses and profinations on the part of those who administer it
and on the part of those who receive it in this sacrament my blood places itself in act over the
contrite sinner in order to descend upon his soul to wash him embellish him heal him and strengthen
him to give back to him the lost grace to place in his hands the keys of heaven which sin has
snatched away from him to impress on his forehead the peacemaking kiss of forgiveness what a beautiful
expression but ah how many harrowing mones in seeing souls approaching the sacrament of penance
without sorrow out of habit almost as a vent of the human heart they just want to talk to somebody
others horrible to be said instead of going to find the life of their souls of grace go to find
death to pour out their passions so the sacrament is reduced to a mockery to a nice chat out
and my blood instead of descending as a bath descends us fire which withers them even more
and so in each confession our love cries inconsolably and sobbing repeats human in gratitude how great
you are everywhere you try to offend me and while i offer you life you turn the very life i offer
you into death see then how our moons await your acquittal in the love of the sacrament of penance
i think i better finish this because we can't really come back to it next week so let's go on
to the holy Eucharist do not let your love stop go through all the tabernacles through each
sacramental host and in each host you will hear the holy spirit moan with on offerable sorrow
the sacrament of the Eucharist is not only their own life that souls receive but it is my very life
that gives itself to them so the fruit of this sacrament is to form my life in them and each
communion serves to make my life grow to develop it in such a way that one may be able to say
i am another christ and alter christus but alas how few take advantage of it even more how many
times i descend into hearts and they make me find the weapons to wound me and repeat for me the
tragedy of my passion and as the sacramental species are consumed instead of pressing me to stay with
them i am forced to leave bathed with tears crying over my sacramental lot and i find no one who calms
my crying and my sorrowful moans if you could break those veils of the host which cover me you
would find me bathed in crying knowing the lot that awaits me in descending into hearts therefore
let your required love love for each host be continuous each host in order to calm my crying
and to render less sorrowful the moans of the holy spirit do not stop he said otherwise we will
not find you always together with us in our moans and in our secret tears we will feel the void of
your required love love descend into the sacrament of ordination here yes you will find our most
intimate hidden sorrows our most bitter tears our most harrowing moans the ordination constitutes
man to a supreme height to a divine character the repeater of my life the administrator of the
sacraments the revealer of my secrets of my gospel of my most sacred knowledge the peacemaker between
heaven and earth the bearer of jesus to souls but alas how many times we see in the ordained one
how he will be a judus for us a usurper of the character which is being impressed on him oh how
the holy spirit moans and seeing in the ordained one the most sacred things the greatest character
which exists between heaven and earth being snatched away from him how many profinations each act of
this ordained one not done according to the character impressed will be a cry of sorrow a bitter crying
a harrowing moan the ordination is the sacrament which encloses all other sacraments together
therefore if the ordained one is able to preserve whole within himself the character he has received
he will almost place all the other sacraments in safety look at the value of one good priest
he will be the defender and the savior of jesus christ jesus is saying that
the priest is the one who must save jesus from all the profinations that can happen in these
sacraments it's incredible but not seeing this in the ordained one our sorrows are sharpened more
our moans become more continuous and sorrowful therefore let your requital of love flow in each
priestly act to keep company with the moaning love of the holy spirit
lend us the ear of your heart and listen to our profound moans in the sacrament of marriage
how many disorders in it marriage was elevated by me to a sacrament in order to place in it
a sacred bond the symbol of the sacrosanct Trinity the divine love which it encloses so the love
which was to reign in the father mother and children the concord the peace was to symbolize
the celestial family i was to have on earth as many other families similar to the family of the
creator destined to populate the earth like many terrestrial angels i love that language
to then bring them back to populate the celestial regions look at the incredible gift of marriage
you populate the earth to populate heaven but ah how many moans in seeing families of sin being
formed in the marriage families which symbolize hell with discord with lack of love with hatred
and which populate the earth like many rebellious angels who will serve to populate hell
the holy spirit moans with harrowing moans in each marriage in seeing so many infernal
dens being formed on the earth therefore place your requital of love in each marriage
in each creature which comes to the light in this way your loving moan will render less sorrowful
our continual moans can't you see there that were be given detailed information as to how to make
reparation for everything finally our moans are not yet finished therefore let your requital of love
reach the bed of the dying one when the sacrament of extreme unction administered but ah how many
moans and how many of our secret tears the sacrament has the power of placing the dying sinner in safety
at any cost it is the confirmation of sanctity for the good and for the holy it is the last bond
which it establishes through its unction between the creature and god it is the seal of heaven
which it impresses on the redeemed soul it is the infusion of the merits of the redeemer in
order to enrich her purify her and embellish her it is the final brush stroke which the holy spirit
gives her in order to dispose her to depart from the earth so as to make her appear before her
creator in sum the extreme unction is the final display of our love the final clothing of the soul
it is the rearranging of all the good works therefore it acts in a surprising way and those who are alive
to grace with the extreme unction the soul is as though covered by a celestial Jew which extinguishes
as though in one breath or passions or attachment to the earth and all that does not belong to heaven
for the last how many moans how many bitter tears how many in dispositions and how many
negligence how many losses of souls and in our day how few people receive this sacrament how
few the sanctities it finds to be confirmed how scarce the good works to be reordered and rearranged
oh if all could hear our moans are crying over the bed of the dying the dying one in the active
administering the sacrament of extreme unction they would cry with sorrow do you not want then to give
us your requital of love for each time this sacrament is administered which is the final display of
our love towards the creature our will awaits you everywhere to have your requital of love and
your company with our moans and size i wanted to finish that for the simple reason that we have
now been told in great detail how to actually make reparation so thank you for coming god bless